[Music]
my name is saya Margolis I direct the
cloud platform practice at sada systems
and sawdust had the pleasure of working
with our panelists to help them with
their cloud journey and so I want to go
through the panel here just to give a
quick introduction ask everyone to maybe
introduce yourself and talk a little bit
about what you do so without further ado
Anastasia is the Mishlove with Realty
Elise Thank You Simon
my name is Anastasia and over seven
years ago I co-founded a company which
name is rel Tia and our goal was to
build product that allows to organize
all of the enterprise data in one single
place so let me give you an example
let's say I'm working in wealth
management company and there are not
that many opportunities and finding new
clients is extremely hard so let's say
in my system I have person whose name is
Scott and he's software engineer and
most likely I'll be not targeting this
person but from other sources from from
the enterprise I realized that there are
more details about Scott Scott is
working in company XYZ and recently in
the news we learned that it has very
successful round of funding and based on
all statistics through the enterprise we
we know that this kind of companies are
going I peel and there are more details
Scott is actually was the first
developer in this company so now you see
that all this context is giving
completely different flavor to Scott and
now as a person working in wealth
management company I need to reach out
to this person as fast as possible
because two years from now it will be
already too late but the problem is that
in enterprise there's no single place
where I could get all of this
information together that's why at r LT
o our mission was to build a place where
I can have reliable data from all over
enterprise that I can transform into
relevant insights and also want to have
Commendation framework so me instead of
scanning through millions of profiles of
Scots I can have just an alert in the
system hey Stasia you need to work with
this with this person and if you think
about enterprise it was example about
wealth management but in every in every
enterprise there are the same kind of
problems you want to leverage all the
information about individuals
organizations products to drive your
business Thank You Stacey so the next
Aaron Brown with mad hype if you could
tell us a little bit about yourself
yeah hi my name is Aaron I work at man
high from the VP of Engineering Matt
hive is a new york-based ad tech firm
for those who don't know hat tech is
sort of the science and infrastructure
behind advertising and that comes with a
lot of engineering challenges we deal
with very very large scale they're
real-time exchanges for ads you know
advertisers don't know where you're
gonna go on the internet next and you
just sort of appear and we have to make
sure that the right advertisement gets
there and there are a whole lot more ads
on the internet than just about anything
else so it it gets big and the data
science is also very important you know
if we show you the wrong ad then you're
just gonna pass off and that's you know
money lost the other thing we work on
very heavily is privacy and that's
almost sort of contradictory in that
industry but privacy is very very
important we believe privacy is a human
right first and foremost and advertising
is kind of creepy in that regard sort of
follow you around everywhere you look to
that bicycle on Amazon one time and just
like everywhere you go that's sort of
weird and you know even an innocent case
a little creepy and the nefarious cases
are very creepy so we like to stop that
and also advertising has problems
because because of that huge scale and
because of those very very low latency
requirements there are tons and tons of
companies involved in the advertising
supply chain like maybe sometimes 20
companies just to show you one ad
and when you have 20 companies sort of
working on data in industry where data
is your value so you want to work
together and check notes but you don't
want to show each other anything what
happens is there are very very large
discrepancies sometimes in the order of
10% which is not great because ads are
kind of like digital money or like the
original digital currency you know each
one of those little ads is some money
and when you're being fast and loose
with people's money you know it's it's a
big problem so we try to solve all these
things at once with privacy so privacy
is about sort of securing data to make
sure that it's not tampered with always
in your control and this works really
well for US consumers and also works
really really well for us in the ad tech
business because now when data has sort
of provenance and sort of control the
you know stuff like doing accounting
auditing it's really really easy
awesome thank you and so Josh gray
principal architect with Citrix if you
could tell us a little bit about
yourself all right thanks thanks Simon
I actually just joined Citrix a few
months ago when they acquired my last
company called CID exes and what we did
it's a Texas is for about the last nine
years we built a the largest community
of global internet performance data in
the world and we started about 2009 and
grew it to a place where we see about a
billion users every day we collect tens
of billions of data points and we
aggregate that all to to give insight
into what's really going on in the
Internet so we effectively measure every
major public provider of infrastructure
many may provide errs of infrastructure
we watch whether there's congestion
weather how the throughput is behaving
what the round-trip times look like we
roll all that data through a very rich
analytics and reporting infrastructure
and we also do very active very low
latency global traffic management based
on that so there's a lot of very high
scale very high speed very low latency
use cases that that we deal with the
nature of the business that we're in
is that we are actually consumers of
virtually all of these providers that we
monitor and so you know we keep an eye
on them but we also run a 24/7 365
global service on top of them and and
Google is has been our fastest growing
vendor that we use as its continued to
capture use cases in our own
infrastructure we continue to be multi
cloud multi vendor and that will likely
continue but you know on the merits of
what we see with the use cases that we
capture it's been it's been really
exciting journey to to keep to keep
moving things forward awesome Thank You
Josh
and then last we'll go to Glen Pringle
innovation lead at Monash University
thanks Simon
so Monash University is the largest
university in Australia so we although
we're only 60 years old
we've got presence across four
continents and we have well we're number
one University for engineering and
technology in Australia as well being
such a large University we've got a
really diverse set of needs so we have
numerous researchers we're a research
intensive University and they have
enormous different needs
we have educators we have a very large
number of students and we've actually
found that we are using cloud more and
more so that they can meet a lot of
those diverse needs
so as an innovation lead I'm working
with those people and looking to really
help them to make use of cloud and in
particular Google cloud to achieve that
awesome Thank You Glen and I'll actually
start with you since you're holding the
microphone so you know I wanted to ask
you a little bit about what really drove
you to start adopting the cloud and then
if you could talk a little bit about why
Google cloud in particular stood out to
you yes sure so we didn't actually
approach cloud looking to reduce cost so
we're looking for a number of things so
we're really looking for flexibility so
as we're trying to to achieve those
things I mentioned earlier we're wanting
solutions where we can quickly and
easily be able to use the resources
looking for a real range of different
resources to do a lot of different
things speed of delivery is a really big
thing too so previously if we're working
with infrastructure that took a lot of
time to prepare to get that
infrastructure ready to bring it into
production whereas when we're going with
cloud it's available when we need it and
it's not just being able to bring it in
instantly it's also about being able to
use that really wide range of different
resources and bring them in as we need
them and scalability as I already
mentioned being able to ramp up with the
infrastructure when when we used to run
into problems we would have to go and
order new hardware so if we want to
scale up they'll be up two months time
before that became available whereas
once we're in the cloud we now see that
using auto scaling that hardware that
that compute is available before we even
know that we need it so as we look at
the the issues around people process and
technology we've actually found that
using cloud takes technology out of that
it becomes a simplest part of those
three and we no longer really struggling
to to deal with that technology side
like we used to be that's awesome that's
good to know so actually maybe the next
question right next to you is for Josh
we didn't plan this really yeah this is
only starting well we'll have to play
hot microphone in a little bit so you
know you mentioned you you you've worked
in a few different cloud providers you
work in a few different environments
overall you know what challenges were
you looking to solve they kind of led
you towards looking for some
alternatives to what you already had in
your wheelhouse and eventually to Google
yes or our early use case that that kind
of brought us to to Google cloud as we
we have really really really large data
sets you know tens of billions of rows
with hundreds of columns and attributes
that you know are collected constantly
and we have a lot of really low latency
cases to get inside
our data our data gets a lot less
interesting the more time passes and so
as days weeks hours go by if that's how
long it takes to get results sometimes
that's not not meaningful anymore so our
main use case was to extract more
valuable information out of our datasets
and make it more accessible to our teams
and so we we ended up looking through a
lot of different data architectures and
I have tried virtually everything that
exists and got really attracted to
bigquery early on and push it hard you
know we had we had many millions of
tables of data did some good work with
the with the BQ team on refining our
approaches so that it aligned with their
expectations and ended up getting some
really really amazing results and and to
me you know there's a lot of solutions
out there there's a lot of options for
data and analytics and and that kind of
approach but what really made the
difference is it was truly a managed
service you just kind of dump data into
it and then you have sequel access to it
and you don't have to think about things
like instant sizing or you know there's
there's truly a managed layer to it that
just works and the fact that I could do
multi terabyte you know inquiries with
sequel which vast majority of my team
was already familiar with really made it
so that people started pulling out value
a lot more easily there was no training
no specialized familiarity of a new
framework or a new programming model
that that had to be done so you know
that that got us kind of into the
bigquery and it's it it has been a large
part of our infrastructure for several
years now and we continue to grow and
and push that and then we've we've
actually been layering in other use
cases we do a lot of things just with
with instances and global management we
do a lot of edge computing and you know
the the quality of engineering result
again we're in the business of watching
all these cloud providers and all these
CD ends and all these data centers so we
get it we get a tremendous amount of
data not just through our own collection
but also with our customers who help us
collect this data and just on the merits
of a lot of these like the the
engineering of the edge platform between
the cloud
this is just a really impressive work a
lot of the capabilities for very rapid
changing of virtualized resources again
really really really good results and as
a result we've had you know increasing
tears through our stack that have gotten
picked up with you know solutions that
are running on Google cloud so yeah
that's great so it sounds like there
were some unique things to GCP that kind
of allowed you to do things you
otherwise would have I guess had a lot
of pain around yeah it was it was
absolutely true there's one other
dimension too is a lot of the offerings
they were externalize ations a very
mature technology like you know big
queries based on the drummel paper which
is you know Tenace years old so not only
had there been a lot of good thinking
good work but it had you know the
solution had a lot of miles on it with
their own internal usage and we've we've
found that frequently that you know even
the newer offerings there they're new to
us on the outside but a lot of them have
been in use for you know five ten years
and have a lot of experience baked into
both the implementation the design that
really really makes for a really really
solid offering yeah thank you for that
so next question actually is for
eustacia and it's a relatively similar
question which is you know we know you
shifted over to use GCP for some of your
workloads can you explain sort of why
you chose GCP and what kind of workloads
you're using it for sure there were
actually different stages for us moving
to Google cloud with different
motivations so let me let me cover some
of the use cases maybe you can correlate
to yours
so the first use case we were running
our platform in Amazon and we had a lot
of api's that users were using you eyes
yo and we wanted to understand what's
the usage of the platform what customers
are doing was the cost for different
customers so we collected all of this
information in in one single place and
it was Google bigquery where we could
store all of this information at very
cheap cost and then have querying
mechanism on top of it so we could build
the reports that we can use internally
as well as share with customers and then
there's also very nice addition Google
have a product called
called Google data studio that allows to
visualize it's kind of bi tool so it
allows to visualize for us the reports
and again share with customers and
ourselves understanding what is actually
happening so this is the first use case
it was long before when we emigrated the
whole platform another use case was we
wanted to build product from scratch and
we decided to go with relatively small
team of developers and deliver this
product as fast as possible without any
DevOps so for this we used managed
services from Google
we used App Engine with all the caches
with indexes that are there with
datastore and we were able to deliver
this product very fast and one one thing
around this very nice thing when you
roll out this kind of products is it dry
it the cost grows as you grow so
initially if you don't have usage of
that product you're actually not paying
for this much and when you have the
adoption this is when you start playing
as well as the auto scaling that is
still there so right now if you don't
have usage at current moment we are not
paying but when we when there's spike of
request this is when we can easily scale
up and meet the customers requirements
and right now I think the biggest one is
actually when we moved our platform from
Amazon to two to Google and the reason
for this the motivation here was we
wanted to meet requirements for our
customers who wanted to be in Google and
didn't want to be in other cloud
provider so with this it was one of the
motivation other motivations that we
heard is frequently people who are
migrating to Google and get better cost
efficiency and the reason for this is
because of the network that you have
with Google the pricing model and
flexibility how we can switch between
the instance types so it was one of the
motivation another one was we wanted to
mix and
the best technologies from different
cloud providers not tying to specific
cloud provider so if there is a database
that can give like replication across
regions and very fast response time we
would like to wrap it into our product
and give it to our customers
another example is machine learning you
want to take all of this and again give
it to our customers no matter if they
are residing in one cloud or another so
that's that's three use cases why we're
switching to Google cloud yeah there's a
great stories and obviously it's been
great to be a part of that journey and
see those transformations that you've
been able to recognize both from a
technology perspective as well as from a
business perspective yes so actually
Matt if Aaron I have a similar question
for you which is you know we were really
I think I was really lucky to work with
you during the kind of assessment
process for figuring out where you
wanted to run your kind of new workloads
and you have some really interesting
requirements so I wonder if you could
talk a little bit about you know what
those nuanced requirements are and what
the decision making process was like
when you were looking for a cloud
provider yeah well we have a lot of team
in matt hive we've sort of plucked from
other very smart startups and so we
built an early impressive team who have
experience across all clouds and when
you get the best of the best together
they kind of say mmm I want to work on
Google cloud platform it's funny story
we actually tried to hire assignment to
do that and then and then Saturday found
out that oh we don't have to hey first
at it we get Santa for free with Google
that's great
that's the best but like things that
were super important to us for like
rolling out our products were first and
foremost like serverless managed to
everything and we mean that like to the
absolute extreme because when you have
you know these elite engineers what you
don't want me doing is sitting there
restarting ec2 instance all day you know
you want to be paying them to do what
they're absolutely amazing and just like
creating stuff all day and
you know like they talked about google
cloud that's cheaper you know like you
know gigabytes a gigahertz and this and
that yes it's true but like you know
that's like thousands of dollars you
know when you talk about like salaries
that's millions of dollars saved plus
opportunities captured you know it lets
us really outmaneuver lots lots of
companies in the space um and it's
gotten us very quickly here on this
day's talking about we do which is cool
so thanks Google cloud or yeah as far as
and and one of the you know a couple of
things that SATA helped us with was you
know in advertising sometimes the
workloads can get like really really
spiky like really spiky like all of
North America is waiting for 8:00 p.m.
for the show to start and they just wait
and then in that one second there's like
this tsunami of a request that comes at
you there is no product on any cloud
that scales like a pandas standard like
you can just put it and forget it
and that is like absolutely critical to
us because ads are money there's literal
money if you drop one requests that's
lost money yeah I remember working with
you early on we you know identified an
area where I think we saved what was it
maybe a hundred milliseconds of latency
and you were so excited about that
because of all the additional things you
could do with those additional
milliseconds and so yeah I love I love
that story because it really speaks to
what you can do when you're working at
the sort of the scale of what gzp
provides yeah you can do a lot of look
database lookups machine learning work
you can do a lot of stuff in a hundred
milliseconds that's great yeah so as
long as we're talking about large-scale
Josh I think I have a question for you
as well you kind of hinted at this in
your introduction right you process just
a tremendous amount of data and you need
to get insights from that data so can
you tell us a little bit about what
within GCP has helped you overcome the
natural hurdles that come from having to
achieve goals like yours yes scales
skills always something that we design
for and and constantly are evolving and
and you know work on significantly I
mean our business is up many orders of
magnitude you know per every few years
and and now that we've part of a bigger
family with Citrix we're we're
optimistic that we'll that'll keep
moving in the same direction probably at
a faster pace so I'm gonna believe it
right after the talk to go get some work
done
but the the main tools with scale you
know I'll go back to again you know the
the agility a couple things that stand
out is kind of the experience of GCP you
know when you when you look at the api's
they're just generally remarkably well
done and easy to understand and
consistent and that leads to velocity
with how quickly people can write
systems that interact with them that
take advantage of the capabilities that
is not always the true experience across
different you know different providers
were you know the inconsistently ends up
in inconsistency ends up burning time as
you figure things out and get them get
them dialed the services themselves you
know velocity and reactivity you can you
can feel you know whether it's app
engines ability to scale or the load
balancers ability to scale or the
ability to you know hot migrate
instances there's just this underlying
design ethos that that your platform is
at least as fast as you want to go and
that's always good because then you know
you're the limiting factor in your
design and you're not you're not banking
on infrastructure that is going to put a
limit on it that you may not even know
about it may not even be in the
documentation so that's always a really
important aspect and that you know that
in particular is kind of what has pushed
some of our use cases beyond even
bigquery out into you know moving on to
to running on Google's platform how they
approached edge you know we're we're all
about speed you know we we run out of
about a hundred different points on the
planet because we do among other things
Global DNS services and you know that's
where you know 10 or 20 milliseconds is
a lot you don't want to take that you
don't want to try you don't want to
spend that in transit time for somebody
to be able to get an answer for you and
being able to take advantage of you know
the breadth of the data centers and the
data center growth and the commitment to
expand
and in the architecture of that edge you
know were they they any caste external
IPS and have some capabilities to you
know bring your resources for
fulfillment you know closer to where the
requests originate those are all really
really important features and and things
that have you know earned the respect of
our team as they explore and develop and
grow on those kinds of capabilities so
yeah and I think it's worth mentioning
you mentioned the acquisition but prior
to that you were really doing a lot of
this with a very small team I imagine
there's a lot of what GCP offers that
kind of facilitated that right yeah yeah
we we had 20-some engineers and and we
you know we deliver many billions of
mission-critical decisions and collect
many tens of billions of data points
every day for companies like LinkedIn
and Pinterest and Airbnb
we're running as part of the plumbing
that delivers all of those sites to you
and again we do that with you know
20-some engineers and and a lot of
that's about choosing very carefully you
know I talked about you know the
efficiency of the API is and the
efficiency of the tooling and taking
advantage of the right managed tiers for
the right services you know you're not
always running raw instances we do some
of that for our highly custom stuff but
you're also taking advantage of things
like bigquery for manager one I don't
have to worry about managing a data pool
and I don't have to worry about deciding
on my sharding and scaling I just dump
data in and put sequel against it and
out of the chute with no more investment
than that I get pretty darn good results
and I can actually even then grow from
there to get into some more specialized
use cases and it's it's it's like Erin
mentioned too that you know you want
your people spending their time on the
most important part of your solution you
don't want them spending their time on
the parts that somebody else frankly can
do and can do better than you and the
implicit part of that that I wanted to
talk about is you're also by extension
taking those people who run the managed
services as part of your team if they
mess up their service that results in
your service not not being of the
quality that you want to do and so you
know which products you choose and the
quality of the product they've built and
the quality of the team that runs it you
know is
important and across a variety of
providers and a variety of products I
think we've all seen that that isn't
always a super high bar and so you know
choosing carefully is is an important
part to maintaining team velocity and
scaling you know so that 20 people can
run something that that runs
mission-critical services for for so
many companies around the globe yeah
that's that's a great perspective and so
continuing this theme of massive scale
you know Glen I would like to turn to
you as well I think we've had the unique
privilege of working together on two
distinct projects right a massive G
suite project and then similarly massive
GCP implementation you know being that
Monash is one of the largest
universities in terms of G suite users
certainly the largest university in
Australia in terms of students can you
tell me a little bit about what
synergies you found between G suite and
g CP especially on the scale you're
operating on so we initially went with G
suite back in 2009 so at that point in
time we were one of the largest
organizations well definitely the
largest university in Australia going
with G suite but one of the largest in
the world and we rolled that out over a
couple of years and since that time
we've seen a constant growth in the use
of G suite so right now we've got about
a hundred and twenty thousand active
users within G suite and we've continued
to see a lot of increase in the use of
the various apps and as we have pretty
much every active student and staff
member using it it's a very natural
progression for a lot of those users who
want to do a little bit more to be able
to move into using GCP there is no
effort for them to actually begin using
GCP so with other systems they often
have to go and get access given to them
they need to be given to the resources
whereas because they're all Jesus we
Google users through G suite they can
then just begin using G CP
and it's been interesting watching over
the last couple of years especially how
a lot of our students are beginning to
try a lot of different things they're
developing projects on their own in some
cases our researchers they can very
easily get access to resources that
otherwise that have to go through all
sorts of other mechanisms to get those
resources so just the fact that they're
Google uses every single day makes it
really really easy to make that
transition yeah that's great and you
know things you're able to talk about
where you're able to enable your
students to do really impressive work I
think it's a great story that is I think
unique to Monash so that's that's very
cool to see so Stacey I think back to
you soon yes see I didn't plan this all
that well you know we again we got to
work together on your migration to GCP
well I'd love to stand up here and say
everything went fantastically and we hit
no roadblocks certainly that's not the
case as you find in large-scale
migration projects could you tell us a
lot about what hurdles you ran into
during your shift to GCP and what you
did to overcome them so actually there
were not that many problems during the
migration so we had really great support
from our Google team and from Sarah with
a lot of experience doing this kind of
project so actually there are not that
many things that that we had challenges
with also the thing that we were
migrating from AWS to disappear a the
architecture itself it was kind of
designed multi-cloud it wasn't relying
on any of managed services from Amazon
and that's why it was like just
rewriting some of the terraform scripts
and running the same kind of workload
but on on Google Cloud so the whole
project from the beginning when we were
making the design how to be working in
Google through the testing as well as
data migration for some of the customers
it took two months after two months we
already were having the first customer
who was leveraging
our platform in Google Cloud I would say
that if at that point we were using
kubernetes then this whole migration
could take much shorter timeframe there
were some lessons learned though
especially on the pricing side so
something that you need to you need to
think about
so basically typically your services
would be breaking down into two
categories the first one is a server
stateless another stateful so for
stateless it's critical to do to use the
ODA scaling and certainly you can go
with an alternative for the with using
App Engine but we wanted to have more
control and have faster migration to
Google cloud so in this case think of
the or your scalability so you need to -
if you want to have the cost efficiency
for the baseline capacity it's better to
to go with commit use nodes and then you
will have the discount for those but for
the auto scale part which is typically
80% of your cluster go with p.m. tables
the benefits of this you'll have the
bigger discount you'll have better
better cost model but those nodes could
be taken at any time but for Auto scale
it should be fine for the stateful if
you have an ability to switch to managed
service this will be the best so first
of all the order scale is is there that
typically you will not get from this
from the database that you are managing
as well as the cost because of the
multi-tenancy that Google already take
care of you if you have to manage your
database then go and buy all the
instances as community use nodes because
typically databases are not scaling down
so these are the main lessons that we
learned that were different from from
Amazon absolutely it seems to be a
recurring theme where there's this need
amongst many of our customers to look at
I mean as we all see from this
conference there's a lot of stuff that
Google is doing some really really cool
powerful things that are sort of new to
the market and so this is something we
see regularly is the need to look at all
of these offerings and figure
what are the best tools for your use
cases and actually Aaron the next
question would be for you on that same
thread because you're using a lot of app
engine you're using a lot a big table
these are things that are somewhat
unique to Google can you talk a little
bit about what makes those advantages
for your business versus your
competition oh yeah that's easy these
are the things that just scale
absolutely infinitely like a big table
was like on my first look into like the
potential here for Google as a platform
for advertising when we're just sort of
getting our feet wet running some
queries and getting results back as fast
as I'm at the network card on my machine
in the office could go I knew we were
sort of on to something
and since then it's only been more more
and more you know that like out of the
box it's phenomenal when you add on like
more layers so you know that that great
engineering team has sort of made it to
incredible magic
I can't imagine sort of doing
advertising at the scale that Matt how
does you know running a bunch of like
sharded like my sequel and nginx and
stuff like that like it just wouldn't
happen and so yeah a surprise Google
knows a thing about advertising and sort
of SATA has sort of helped us stay very
googly inside of Matt hive and yes it's
a great resource for us to have yeah
like you said you have a small team of
really bright people you don't waste
their time managing this stuff they
don't have to manage know they have
enough worth to do already right so
actually going my next questions for you
you know Monash University has a lot
going on right it's a massive University
so can you tell us a little bit about
what you're seeing in terms of the
ability to better innovate across the
campus by leveraging GCP sure so as a
couple of people have already mentioned
Google App Engine provides a lot of
opportunity and we we almost exclusively
use that aspect of
GCP and it provides us the opportunity
to to both cheaply and easily put into
place customized solutions to different
problems and as a couple of examples of
the sorts of things that we're seeing we
recently had the campus security group
approaches and they had an issue that
they wanted to be able to tree track the
shuttle buses that run around campus and
in the lead-up to the exam period they
wanted the students to be able to find
when that bus was going to arrive so
that they could know where to head for
and when to get there to be able to get
to their exam and a previous solution
that they had had fallen apart and we
had almost no time to develop this in
and so within five days we were able to
with one dev one engineer put together a
solution we used a IOT devices on those
buses and from there we imported the
data we use Google App Engine firebase
and also Google Maps and we had a
solution up from very start of the
request coming into to the working
solution within five days and that's the
sort of thing that it's just about
impossible to achieve using other
methods so in terms of quick and easy
pulling together different components
that worked really well for us now
another another problem and this is a
different scale so the Institute of
railway technology is a group within our
University who deal with a lot of issues
on railroads and they have a lot of
monitoring analytics and those sorts of
things and they work with mining trains
that run in the outback of Australia so
some of the harshest conditions you can
get on the planet and as what are the
interesting things they they put
tracking equipment on these trains and I
was talking to Simon about this the
other night
if something goes wrong with these
devices it can be up to two years before
they can get access to be able to
replace them so when you talk about
downtime if something goes wrong as
rarely you get more than a couple years
downtime so they've got to be sure that
everything works really well and so
these IOT devices are tracking a whole
range of different things so they're
tracking things like vibrations sound
location all sorts of different things
and the idea is that they want to be
able to understand where sections of
track actually need maintenance and so
that data is being fed back to Google
where we can do analytics on it and
there's a whole range of different
components that we can pull together
from GCP to actually do that so one of
the most exciting areas that I'm
actually finding with that is in the
whole ml space and things like Auto ml
vision other things like that are
providing enormous opportunities to
actually enhance what we can do in this
area yes I think we're hearing a theme
here where you're able to do a whole lot
more with a whole lot less in terms of
human resources in terms of time to
deployment even in terms of scale in the
case of IRT so that's that's really
interesting on that same vein Josh I
know when we started working together
you were dealing with a well relatively
speaking much smaller deal of data than
you are today so can you talk a little
bit about what if anything really had to
change in order to accommodate the
significant increase in volume that you
encounter today yeah so I mean we've
been on kind of a classic startup path
you know you start with one and you're
super excited about your first customer
that brings you a little bit of traffic
and then you just you just kind of kind
of grow and grow and grow and now we're
you know we're part of the Citrix family
and Citrix is all about you know choice
and cloud and optimizing and mobilizing
you know delivery of data and apps and
and we're really excited about about
playing a significant role in that and
that you know our architecture and our
product has kind of
evolved you know several times as as as
we've gotten larger and as we've we've
taken on more more vendors on day one we
we operated I think we might have had a
little bit of Amazon but we did a lot of
like least iron and coalos and and least
infrastructure from seedy ends and there
was a lot of interesting early
architecture a lot of the ways that
we've evolved that to to deal with scale
again was to continue to leverage the
fact that our system is very layered and
has a lot of micro services and has a
lot of internal decomposition so that we
could we can move those things forward
the nice side effect that is we can we
can move entire tiers of our internal
operations you know in how they operate
what technologies they use what vendors
they use and we do that all you know
while running a 24/7 365 zero downtime
operation you know we don't get to say
I'm sorry we're not going to resolve DNS
names for the next two hours because we
need to do some work on the system any
given second of every single day you
know we will get hundreds of thousands
of requests sometimes many more as Aaron
is talking about you know a lot of our
customers deal with news and media and
things like that and so sometimes you
will get spikes we do a lot of work with
game delivery you know Christmas morning
is a remarkable time for us as well
because everybody's opening up their
their game consoles and downloading
updates to all of their all of their
games and and you get this incredibly
spiky sometimes very unpredictable I
mean you could predict it's gonna happen
on Christmas morning but you never quite
know how large it's going to be or
exactly when it'll hit or things like
that so you need to keep you know
leveraging that the layers in your
system can be as reactive and adaptive
and resilient in in everything and
that's been a key as we've evolved and
it's a big reason why we've taken on you
know the layers that we've taken on that
we've moved into Google cloud because
they they delivered uniquely reactive
uniquely resilient
you know capabilities that that
that we leverage and some of sometimes
the the it really matters in the details
you know a lot of people talk about Auto
this or Auto that but when you actually
peel the onion a little bit and do some
testing well it's sort of Auto and it's
sort of fast and it might take a few
minutes or a few hours or you might have
a hard limit on the resources in the
data center and those things are all
really important because at the end of
the day our customers don't care
you know we either deliver the service
or we don't and and the latter is really
not an option for us and so you know we
choose our vendors wisely we choose our
technologies wisely and and and we've
been you know continuing to evolve that
the one last point is you know being
part of the Citrix family has been
really exciting because we're you know
leveraging a lot of our best practices
across some of the other cloud offerings
and and desktop delivery offerings and
and cloud utilization scenarios so you
know we're we're looking forward to
bringing a lot of that same kind of
mentality and approach to the broader
offerings and the good work that you
know they're already doing in a lot of
those spaces so yeah it's it's an
awesome insight that you're able to
provide because I think you know your
team generally has stayed pretty similar
in size and echoing what the other
panelists have said you've really been
able to do so much more by you know
leveraging various components of you
know what cloud has to offer so I think
it's a that's a great story
so Erin I have another one for you
just because this is my one of my
favorite things to talk about
we joke all the time right that you deal
with blockchain and you deal with cloud
computing and other any other buzzwords
that I'm missing oh yeah so you know
these sound like I'm just trying to like
you know sell a white paper or something
by saying blockchain and cloud computing
in the same sentence but it's what
you're really doing can you tell us a
little bit about what those things do
together and how you're able to you know
achieve what you do using those
technologies yeah this is a really good
question that we get a lot because it's
not a secret that were very big users of
Google cloud and we're also very active
in the blogging community our
researchers that ik a tons of time to it
we have a lot of contributions that were
super proud of but people who are
familiar with blockchain are like hey
this is like literally like cloud
competitor like you know it's cloud is
all about centralization and you know
like you know Authority and blockchain
is all about decentralization and not
having to trust you know knowing things
are true through cryptography they
actually work really really well
together so if you recall like what we
talked about in the beginning about like
one of the big problems in advertising
is auditing you know like it's tons its
litter ants or literally money and
they're there even the auditing standard
should even be higher because this is
the case where unlike in like you know
banking a Wall Street where you know
there are shares and dollars and things
that go around ads get like made you
just create money and if you have
opportunity to create money and you have
like a lot of opacity in the supply
chain there's gonna be problems so one
of the things that we do is sort of our
walk back to this whole process is you
can use cryptography cryptography is
more than just like you know like
encrypting messages cryptography is
about also like you know validating the
integrity of data without necessarily
revealing why so for example if we have
like rest endpoints
you know most rest endpoints are like
you know like there's a web request it
does a database query and then it gives
back a result we can do things like with
the addition of cryptography on this we
can make it that the data even though
you didn't reveal what happened
underneath we can reveal the provenance
and sort of the supply chain that data
and then that's super useful because now
it's just as easy as a rest endpoint but
now you know I get to know okay this
data has some validity it went through
partners and it went through transforms
and I don't have to know exactly what
those transforms were to know that it's
correct because even one thing changed
everything just breaks cryptography is
need like that the other thing we can do
is
you want sort of some universal base so
you know where have this this the string
almost I've carries through all the data
as it goes through the supply chain and
that's where the blockchain part really
comes in it becomes really useful
because that is our universal truth
where everyone in the industry is
working really really hard to maintain
this just some base level of truth and
the math it's complicated but just you
know say like we're all agreeing that
number is five number is five right now
and that's where I'll anchor our strings
and now through the cross the entire
ecosystem we're doing you know rest
calls database lookups queries
transforms behind people servers in
large data centers but we know with
absolute cryptographic certainty that
the answers are correct and also when
we're done sharing data that we can
revoke that and immediately it goes all
the way through the supply chain not by
trust not by contracts not even by
privacy laws like the new European
regulation for privacy gtp are literally
by the force of physics cryptography and
that's a really really exciting solution
to be able to offer in our industry and
we've been working with the blockchain
standards body for advertising called ad
ledger we're also one of the founders
along with IBM and techni and a bunch of
large companies and so we're happy to
make that contribution but I think the
most exciting thing about that sort of
combination is like you talked about
cloud and blockchain you know I've been
attending a lot of the sessions here
about machine learning and you know like
Google and cloud is all about AI a
machine learning like that is the the
killer use case but machine learning and
AI are only as good as the data that you
can source and what Google has done an
amazing job of collecting not like tons
of tons of data in one place and it
shows in their products there is a limit
to that because we can't all sort of
share our like business data or as
consumers or private data
and we probably don't even want that to
go into these big machine learning
things and so that is like a hard stop
for the evolution of AI it shouldn't
have to be like that we can use the same
privacy techniques that we discussed for
consumers and across these no data
supply chains and you can put that into
machine learning and that's like the
killer app like AI plus cryptography is
like that's like everything that's like
literally the new internet yeah we're
gonna be talking about here in the next
decade yeah no I love that story because
I think that is the common misconception
is that these are somehow competing
technologies but you really do paint the
picture as to how these things can
actually be very complementary and I
love squashing that that bad stereotype
so unfortunately I think we're just
about out of time here so I just wanted
to thank all of you for being here with
us thank you all for attending and we
will all be somewhere around here
afterwards if anyone has any questions
for us so thank you everyone
you
[Music]